hey guys Pete peppers here taking a look
at the new game and the farm heroes
series I think it's gonna be called farm
here a super saga it's been out in the
under the name of Eden harvest it might
be a some combination of those two but I
feel like there's gonna be some
reference to farm eros in the name since
it's obviously you know like candy crush
candy crush soda so always seem now when
we look at the opening screen is Eden
harvest so we'll see what happens but um
I think it'll be coming out pretty soon
actually that's why I'm making this
video now there's 145 levels and there's
been a bunch of updates over the
previous months so I feel like the games
pretty complete at this point so I'm
gonna go ahead and roll this back you
can see the maps pretty cool it does the
scroll will look at the game mechanics
and talk about some things and check it
out see what you think I've never been a
huge farm heroes player I played it
quite a bit but you know I've never it's
never been my main game I always kind of
liked it though and I feel like this is
even cooler in a lot of ways I mean I'm
sure people who have been playing since
you know farm heroes was big when it
first came out you know probably might
feel a little bit different but they
just made a lot of cool improvements so
you could see here we got a line up our
line up our matches we have to collect
most of them are collecting and farm
hero so in this very first level it
doesn't even show the the counter I
should have skipped ahead I guess but
you see how it works we match each time
we at each time we collect we get more
towards our count and once we get to 20
the level is complete there we go
so not not a whole lot new and that this
is new obviously we have these prized
crops and you can see their numbers are
on there you make those I'll show you
how to make those in a second but for
this show time thing which is like what
was it called in the first one it was
called well I can't think right now but
it was you know that you can collect
extra here's the thing with the crops
you can see they have those numbers on
them so that's what we want to do is
raise that number and then we get to our
collection totals faster so I'll just
skip up to like sea level 6 see the
flowers are back we see flowers we see I
haven't seen any eggs yet but definitely
some flowers just and they work exactly
the same and I see how the crop we're
next to matches that I made they get a
number on them so we collect those
faster so just kind of keep track of
that when you're playing because you get
to show time a little bit faster that
way alright so you saw I was gonna say
yeah whenever you make a bigger one of a
color that you don't need to collect it
just spreads out with numbers on the
nearby ones just like the ones like the
colors that you aren't collecting they
don't get numbers if you make a square
here's how you do it here this will be a
one for a color we need but you just
make it in a square sort of like the
fish and soda saga or jelly saga and
then now this has 14 on and what's cool
about this is is that it doesn't lose
its number like these numbers will go
away if I don't make a match like watch
these yellow ones see how their numbers
are gone
the big one will keep those throughout
the rest of the game so you don't have
to you don't have to match them right
away to get that at the counter so
there's that and some other things that
we see in this game that are cool we
have a we have a squirrel which I'll
show you next and we have which we have
to use him to collect acorns and then
you have the goat which goes after goes
after hey you have to lead them around
and they're similar to the ones on the
other you know like in farm heroes in
the higher levels where you have the
animals and things but I think it's a
little bit I think it's a little bit
smoother and this I don't have enough
experience to like compare it but I feel
like it is it's just easier to
understand or at least it was for me it
was more intuitive so yeah here you go
we got our squirrel there he's a
cool-looking cat and we're gonna bring
this by making matches in that direction
we're gonna bring the acorn through and
you can see we got to point it out
beforehand but this is the other thing
that's different about this game when
you have ones with leaves and yeah I'll
show you that see how the the leaves
blow instead of dropping up and down
like they do in a regular regular match
3 gravity they actually whatever way you
make the match that's the way your
pieces move so that's cool that's a
brand new thing for these fans
so whatever whenever you start the level
you want to see if there's leaves blown
around on there first or not because
that's how you'll be able to
tell how the gravity's gonna rap all
right so this will get it close if you
make a um if you make a big match next
to your squirrel your goat
it'll make it'll make him like the goat
it'll make it jump on a square that's
across the way or with the squirrel
it'll make them stick the tail out
a little bit further so it's always a
good thing to do can't collect any of
the big ones here it's not important
rain looks a lot different on this you
could see he'll he's not always around
but you'll see him hanging it out down
here whenever he is available and he's
not like a boss mode like he was before
where you have to beat him to move on
he'll just be somewhere I'll show you
that in a second I'll show you this the
goat real quick though he'll be
somewhere you can go and play him and
like I said I'll show you in a second so
here's our goat he moves the same way
that the he moves the same way that the
squirrel does he moves towards the match
you see here watch he'll jump and take
something out whenever you make a big
match next to him so that's always good
this is doesn't have any leaves you can
see so it's just straight gravity so
anything we make to this side he's gonna
go to and then he'll skills
he'll post up for the next match and
then we can move on again so like if we
want to move into this square we can
make this match right here and he'll
pick up that piece and then like if we
make on a leaves level we'd have to like
actually move this one left or right to
left but since it's not a leaf when we
can just go ahead and go like right here
and he'll still go that way because you
can only get you know I mean they only
go up and down and that'll make him jump
on our last one so those are cool
there's a cool mode think of what else
is I'll show you the thing in the
beginning real quick about the about how
the how the the leaves things work we
also you also do get coins here and
there's this thing called the crops or
country show ugly yeah you have this
down here and you can earn you can earn
coins with the coins you can buy you can
buy these boosters through the shop here
these ones are the coin once you can get
this ones a water bottle that it'll make
a big crop and this one will pull it up
so sort of like a shovel I haven't used
them yet I'm on 115 I don't like to use
boosters really but I'm sure that'll
come in handy for a lot of people I know
the shovels were really important in the
first game so but yeah here is the see
how the leaves blow across on this one
you could see that means it's it leaves
level where things are going to slide
and the one I was just on no leaves in
this slide so we'll look at look at
rancid real quick just to give you an
idea then I'll finish this up so he
comes he's up at the top your goals are
the same
it doesn't affect but he has these
that are on the board and when we make a
match next to the can it hits them and
that'll that's what sets his bar going
you have to fill his bar and then you
also have to complete the level or you
don't get the points for three points or
so if you finish the level you can still
get progress for it but if you know if
it's a new level if you knock him out
though and don't finish the level then
you don't get the coins anyway so so I
think it's a pretty cool game I think
it'll be really popular especially with
people who liked it like the original
farm heroes you can see that they made a
fair amount of changes I really like the
Wii U's I like those levels the graphics
that come along really well it looks it
looks I think it looks a little other
semantics are really smooth there's not
there's not a ton of new features in
every episode like there are and some of
the ones in the original game but I'm
sure over time though they'll they'll be
the you know they'll keep those up one
thing to think of there you can act you
can switch the can and you can switch
the squirrel like when you're when
you're trying to move the squirrel you
can actually make a switch and he'll
move over for you but with the goat it
doesn't work so that's just a little
thing to keep in mind you'll pick up all
that stuff as you go see if we can't
take him out I need to pick up some some
purple crops too though
if you got any questions about the game
leave one in the bottom make sure you
like it we try to put out all these so
you can get an idea of what to look for
the new game subscribe to my channel
I'll be making videos of all these I'm
finishing up the levels now and it
should be out soon I think I mean I
don't I don't I can't think about
another game that they made 145 level 4
and then didn't release it
soon afterwards so hopefully it won't be
a really long wait so you could see that
since I finished early he got knocked
out we'll just do the Showtime real
quick and I'll finish it up the little
video like I said please subscribe to my
channel so these are levels definitely
leave comments if you need them and like
the video see we want our little prize
here for beating him and I'll talk to
you soon thanks